vor dem möglicherweise entscheidenden
gespräch von bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel und den ministerpräsidenten am
mittwoche fordern immer mehr politiker
lockerungen der korona beschränkungen
die grünen-chefs annalena baerbock und
robert habeck plädieren dafür schulen
und auch kitas nach und nach wieder zu
öffnen aber begleitet von
vorsichtsmaßnahmen sprechen wir darüber
mit grünen fraktionschefin katrin göring
eckardt hallo und willkommen guten
morgen
sie solle es bundeseinheitliche oder
regionale kriterien für einen ausstieg
aus den maßnahmen gegen geben ihrer
meinung nach die grünen chefs halten ja
regionale unterschiedliche maßnahmen für
notwendig aber führt das nicht zu einem
flickenteppich wenn jetzt jedes
bundesland aussteigt wie es möchte
denn darum geht es auch nicht dass jedes
bundesland ausstellen könnte dies möchte
sondern den wesentlichen geht es da von
regionalen besonderheiten auch
anzuerkennen und zu sehen also großen
welche kapazitäten da wo es welche
versorgung da wo welche möglichkeiten
nichtsdestotrotz ist immer alles besser
und dann sind wir uns auch eigentlich
was bundeseinheitlich geschehen kann
damit man sie auf alles verlassen kann
also die leben in berlin auch zu machen
in brandenburg zu das wird natürlich
erste problem führen als zu etwas
anderem
das haben wir in der vergangenheit schon
gesehen als minimale unterschiede gab
mit die einheiten die bauma auf und die
anderen nicht aber das entscheidende ist
ja wir können den langsam schritt für
schritt unter großen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen und immer unter
der prämisse dass die gesundheit vorgeht
wieder aus dieser situation herauskommen
einer der wichtigen oder wichtigsten
schritte ganz am anfang ist das öffnen
der schulen
jetzt wird von den grünen auch gefordert
die schulen wieder zu öffnen auch für
besonders junge schüler also die klassen
eins bis sechs weil die halt betreut
werden müssen damit die eltern wieder
arbeiten gehen können
schutzmaßnahmen soll es trotzdem geben
auch bei diesen jungen altersgruppen wie
sollen die denn durchgesetzt werden
praktisch in diesem alter genau das ist
eine
das ist ja in der tat eine schwierige
situation trotzdem werden lernen wir in
den letzten tagen das ist immer weiter
auseinandergeht ein gutes los problem
haben die anderen führt dass ein bus für
wie das ein großes problem ist deswegen
kann man das nur dann machen damit auch
gewährleisten kann das tatsächlich
schutz durchgeführt werden dann das
bedeutet zunächst einmal dass die
klassen sehr stark verkleinert werden
müssen dass man in der klasse
auseinandersetzen kann das bedeutet dass
man auch sowas schutz durchsetzen kann
und dass es lehrerinnen und lehrer und
gegebenenfalls eben weiter selbst
personen auch durchsetzen können das ist
eine große anstrengung angesichts des
personalmangels cd in der schule haben
und deswegen kann es auch nur heißen
langsam anfangen nicht mit einem
normalbetrieb in der schule und bei dem
kleinen wird es sehr viel gegen darum
dass auf der einen seite lernen
betreuung eben auch stattfindet und auf
der anderen seite gewährleistet ist dass
man das auch durchsetzen kann aber
ehrlicherweise ich weiß nicht wie es
ihnen geht oder also erstklässler sieht
wir wissen schon in aller regel genau
woran sie sich wirklich halten müssen
und darum geht es aber
selbstverständlich
wir sehen hier tragen die schüler vom
agentur die prüfungen müssen gemacht
werden und bei den großen haben wir
sicherlich das drehen da haben sie recht
man heutzutage ab und an sogar kinder in
alter erster klasse zweiter klasse
die dann die erwachsenen anregen doch
abstand zu halten also das ist bei den
kindern tatsächlich schon angekommen
jetzt muss es nur im schulalltag auch
weiter durchgezogen werden diese
schutzmaßnahmen vollkommen richtig
schauen wir auf diese corona studie der
akademie der wissenschaft wie sieht ja
einige maßnahmen sehr kritisch die so in
den letzten wochen monaten angestrebt
worden sind und auch durchgezogen worden
sind die testverfahren während der
kritisch beschrieben es wird von
panikmache gesprochen wenn es darum geht
die tägliche veröffentlichung der
fallzahlen und der todeszahlen die
sterbe risiken werden laut dieser studie
nicht richtig eingeordnet sie als
opposition stellen sie
ich vollumfänglich hinter die maßnahmen
der wissenschafter der regierung
oder sehen sie das ähnlich wie die
wissenschaftler in ihrer studie the pitt
ist es kann viele dinge davon jetzt zum
teil verurteilen und sich wichtig finde
ist dass wir die kritische
auseinandersetzung haben was ich wichtig
finde jetzt wieder debatte auch über
diese maßnahme
wir haben das übrigens von anfang an
gesagt wir die entscheidungen im
deutschen bundestag mitgetragen
die voraussetzung war dass all diese
maßnahmen beschränkt sind das haben wir
innerhalb von wenigen tagen gemacht und
dieses von wenigen tagen heißt natürlich
so etwas muss wieder fehleranfällig sei
nicht abhängig
und ich habe das auch im deutschen
bundestag wenn wir in der politik wird
werden fehler machen und die
entscheidende frage ist ja wird man
solche fehler auch eingestehen können
und man sie kombinieren können ja oder
nein
und das was die leopoldina
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
uns jetzt mit
das ist etwas wo ich sagen würde dass
100 zu überprüfen
ich würde noch nicht einfach von
panikmache reden weil wir waren uns alle
eigentlich dass seine riesigen
gesundheitsgefährdungen als pikanten die
situation in italien anderen ländern und
wollten unter keinen umständen bei uns
in so eine situation kommen das ist
richtig und man ist es sehr wichtig sehr
vorsichtig zu sein und dann jeden tag zu
überprüfen aus welcher situation kann
man denn eigentlich wann auch wieder
heraus und diese öffentliche debatte die
brauchen wir jetzt sollte kein ewiges
hin und her sein dass sollte auch keine
debatte sein nach dem motto werden sich
jetzt als erstes einen exit plan von dem
ministerpräsidenten soll eine von multi
geleitete gemeinsame debatte wir werden
das als opposition aber natürlich auch
als regierung in elf bundesländern und
als die auch im deutschen bundestag
sagen wir gucken da konstruktiv brauchen
bleiben
jetzt wollen sie nach vorne schauend
eine debatte um eine lohn kommission
anstoßen als lehre aus dieser krise
damit pflegekräfte erzieherin
verkäuferinnen besser bezahlt werden
also die menschen die wirklich das land
am laufen gehalten haben und es wieder
tun werden bei der nächsten krise dieser
art ist das
jetzt wieder eine ein versuch der grünen
jetzt heraus aus dieser krise themen
wieder zu setzen nach vorne zu gehen
denn die letzten wochen waren ja nun mal
die wochen der exekutive die union ist
gestiegen in den umfragen sie haben
prozentpunkte verloren ist jetzt die
zeit wieder themen zu setzen aus grüner
sicht der gleichheit ist er ist thema
krise macht es auch eine pause während
die kurse zusätzlich haben
das kann man auch in vielen bereichen
sehen in allen medien inzwischen über
trockenheit und darüber und jetzt
unserer wehr ist aber was ich nicht
möchte ist dass wir über wochen in
dieser krise leben und sie versuchen zu
bewältigen und uns die ganze zeit damit
beschäftigen wie ist es mit den
pflegerinnen wie ist es mit den leuten
im einzelhandel et cetera pp
rettungsschirm aufspannt und sofort und
hinterher einfach weitermachen wie zuvor
das geht aus meiner sicht überhaupt
nicht sondern wir müssen aus dieser zeit
die schlüsse ziehen die lehren ziehen
die wir ziehen können und das heißt auch
eine veränderung der politik
und jetzt kann man sagen jetzt warten
wir mal irgendjemand auf die idee kommt
dass ein bisschen mehr zahlen könnte für
die pflegekräfte oder die angehörigen um
die es da geht oder man kann gleich
sagen das ist es bitte einmal
einheitlich in deutschland betrachten
wir haben alles gute erfahrung mit der
mindestlohn kommission der am anfang
sehr skeptisch
lasst uns betrachten welche löhne für
diese bereiche den tatsächlich
angemessen sind was wird brauchen willst
ja dass wieder mehr menschen dort auch
tatsächlich arbeiten und auch arbeiten
wollen und das ist wirklich gerne
anstoßen durch so eine kommission
aber das ist natürlich nur einem thema
aus dem wir lernen müssen die frage wie
die digitalisierung weiter geht nicht
nur in den schulen sondern auch in all
dem was wir an anderen stellen machen
wird eine weitere entscheidende frage
sein und noch mal die timati besteht